[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
mes chers collègues les conclusions
adoptées par la Conférence des
Présidents réunit le 22 mars sont
consultables sur le site du Sénat
non pas reçu d'observation et je
considère ces conclusions comme adopter
madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en direct
sur Public Sénat et notre site internet
au nom du bureau du Sénat chacun sera
attentif à observer des valeurs
essentielles qui sont le respect des uns
et des autres et le respect du temps de
parole je commence par donner la parole
au président Claude Malhuret pour le
gros plaisant
République et territoire
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président les scènes
de guerre civile qui se sont déroulées
samedi à sainte-solines en scandalisait
les Français
des quarts de gendarmes en feu des
hordes de Black Blocs venus de toute
l'Europe beauté casquée et cagoulés
armée de cocktail Molotov de boules de
pétanque de couteau de machette et de
mortiers c'est
ultra gauche européenne a fait de la
France son terrain de jeu favoris car
elle sait qu'elle y trouvera un relais
politique le relais de ceux qui explique
qu'il faut transformer les révoltes en
révolution par un slogan radical tout
conflictualisé le relais de ceux qui
défilait samedi avec leurs écharpes
tricolores dans une manifestation
interdite illégale et ultra-violente
pistons les forces de l'ordre par des
textos sous les hashtags tout cramés et
c'est la guerre alors que depuis
plusieurs semaines les organisations
syndicales des fils dans le calme et la
responsabilité les émeutiers organisent
désormais partout des cortèges
parallèles brûlent les ordures et
kiosque les portes des mairies et des
préfectures cassent les vitrines des
commerçants saccagent les permanences
des parlementaires menacent de morts les
jeunes enfants des députés frappent des
mers dans les projets ne leur plaisent
pas et en définitif finissent même par
terroriser les manifestants pacifiques
l'ultra gauche pyromane se moque des
retraites et des méga bassines son
objectif c'est l'insurrection sa cible
la République qu'elle est bien décidée à
abattre pour faire de la France un
nouveau Venezuela le ministre de
l'Intérieur a annoncé hier à l'Assemblée
de première sanctions contre certains
des trains de savates incendiaires je
voudrais que vous nous assuriez madame
la Première ministre que votre
gouvernement prendra toutes les mesures
politiques réglementaires judiciaire
pour protéger ceux qui nous protègent
policiers gendarmes pompiers élus et
plus généralement toutes les personnes
menacées par ces factieux les forces de
l'ordre ont eu au cours des dernières
semaines plus de 400 blessés donc 47 le
week-end à Sainte Soline c'est à ce prix
qu'elle nous protège et je voudrais
qu'ici c'est la moindre des choses nous
leur rendions hommage par nos
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
pour vos réponses
pour vos réponses la parole est à madame
la Première ministre vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
madame la Première ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Claude madurès
comme vous et comme bon nombre de nos
compatriotes j'ai été profondément
choquée par le déchaînement de violence
ce samedi à Sainte-Soline contre les
gendarmes contre l'ordre républicain
j'ai été choqué de voir des élus se
rendre en écharpe tricolore à une
manifestation interdite
[Musique]
j'ai été choqué ces dernières semaines
d'entendre des élus multipliées les
propos incendiaires et parfois même
justifier les violences
renvoyer dos à dos casseurs et force de
l'ordre c'est indigne de la part d'élus
de la République
alors aujourd'hui avec vous avec les
Français je veux à mon tour rendre
hommage aux forces de l'ordre à leur
courage et à leur engagement
je veux dire ma solidarité aux gendarmes
et aux policiers qui ont été blessés à
Sainte Soline ou dans les débordements
qui ont malheureusement parfois entouré
les mobilisations ces derniers jours
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
policiers et les gendarmes connaissent
leurs devoirs d'exemplarité et de
respect de la déontologie le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin là encore
rappelé hier des casseurs et des
militants radicalisés venus chercher
l'affrontement et défier nos
institutions sont à l'origine des scènes
que nous avons vu ces derniers jours
notamment à Sainte Soline c'est leur
comportement qui met en danger chacun
policier gendarmes sapeurs-pompiers
secours et même les manifestants alors
de notre côté nous faisons tout pour
éviter que des débordements surviennent
et comme vous tous ici j'ai une pensée
pour les deux manifestants toujours
hospitalisés dans un état très grave
depuis samedi
depuis des semaines le ministre de
l'Intérieur les préfets les forces de
l'ordre au contact des organisations
syndicales travaillent ensemble et ont
permis la tenue de la grande majorité
des mobilisations sans heure nous
continuerons à nous adapter et à réagir
pour que la violence ne supplante jamais
l'expression des revendications c'est le
sens du dispositif qui encadrait la
journée d'hier il a permis d'éviter de
nombreux débordements affrontements
dégradation c'est le sens de la
procédure de dissolution annoncée hier
par le ministre de l'intérieur du groupe
uscules soulèvement de la terre mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs la violence
n'a pas sa place dans les cortèges et
nous sommes déterminés à continuer à
protéger tous ceux qui veulent exprimer
pacifiquement leurs idées à protéger les
Françaises et les Français je vous
remercie merci
la parole est de notre collègue Gilbert
Favreau pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
première méduse madame vous et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
ministolet intérieur monsieur le
ministre ce qui vient de se passer
autour de la retenue d'eau de sainte
Soline dans mon département des
Deux-Sèvres à bouleversé la France
entière
sainte Soline c'est 357 habitants qui
viennent de vivre en moins de 6 mois un
second état de siège je tiens à dire à
ces 357 habitants toute ma compensation
ma compassion et mon total soutien ainsi
qu'aux agriculteurs et aux gendarmes à
quoi avons-nous assister samedi dernier
devant nos écrans de télévisions
certainement pas une manifestation
ordinaire d'ailleurs interdite par la
préfète du département vous avez vu des
centaines de casseurs armés organisés
rompu à l'exercice déterminer à faire
reculer l'État en cassant du gendarme
avec un bilan redoutable des dizaines de
blessés chez les gendarmes et des
manifestants mais aussi avec le soutien
d'élus de la République qui se trouvait
sur le terrain c'est intolérable
monsieur le ministre comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là comment expliquer
qu'en France en 2023 on puisse être
confrontés à une telle violence à
intervalles réguliers le sujet n'est
plus celui de l'eau et pas davantage
celui de l'agriculture le sujet c'est
l'autorité de l'État alors Monsieur le
Ministre quand l'extrême violence semble
habituelle dans ses rassemblements
qu'entendez-vous faire pour restaurer
l'autorité de l'État et mettre un terme
à l'activisme des casseurs qui servent
qui sévissent dans les manifestations
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Gérald larmadame merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
setters monsieur le sénateur je crois
que la première ministre a su répondre
en partie et à votre question mais je
voudrais évidemment avec vous dire tout
mon soutien aux habitants de votre
département à singulièrement à ceux de
Sainte-Souline mais également aux
agriculteurs parce que café l'état
pendant deux weekends de suite qu'on
fait les gendarmes puisque si nous
comptons les deux weekends
d'affrontements c'est plus de 100
gendarmes qui ont été blessés et parfois
très gravement que de protéger l'outil
travail des agriculteurs que de protéger
ces agriculteurs des Deux-Sèvres mais
partout en France qui sont parfois
l'objet de menaces d'intimidation
d'insultes de la part de gens qui
utilisent en effet la violence verbale
et physique pour arriver à leur fin
politique monsieur le sénateur le
ministre de l'Intérieur applique le
droit et la loi de la République il n'a
pas la possibilité d'interpeller les
gens avant que des faits se soient
commis même lorsqu'ils sont connus par
les services de renseignement je
voudrais rappeler d'ailleurs ici que la
proposition de Monsieur Retailleau qui a
été reprise par mon prédécesseur a été
censuré en partie par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui empêche les mises
intérieur qui ne fait qu'appliquer le
droit dans un état droit et de constater
les infractions avant de éventuellement
pouvoir interpeller ces personnes
constatons d'ailleurs que lorsque le
ministre de l'Intérieur fait procéder à
ses interpellations il lui-même critiqué
mais c'est un autre sujet il vaut mieux
critiquer les intérieurs que les que
vomir sur les policiers gendarmes comme
l'a fait une partie de la de gauche et
d'extrême gauche ces derniers jours le
deuxième sujet monsieur le sénateur
c'est qu'il faut faire voler des drones
pour avoir des images qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé à Sainte Soline les casseurs
ont pu faire voler des drones pour
regarder le dispositif des gendarmes et
les policiers les gendarmes vous avez
refusé Mesdames et Messieurs les drones
pour les policiers gendarmes sont les
seuls à ne pas pouvoir faire voler des
drones
alors oui il faut en tirer toutes les
conclusions
je veux quand même souligner le travail
de nos gendarmes courageux il n'y a pas
eu de ZAD à Sainte Soline pendant 2
weekends d'affrontements et c'est aussi
ça à l'autorité de l'État
monsieur Favreau
j'ai remercié les gendarmes monsieur le
ministre mais posons-nous la question
j'ai pris note des explications que vous
m'avez donné mais je crois que nous
sommes dans une ère nouvelle qui a
commencé avec la reculade de l'État à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes
cette reculade a sapé l'autorité de
l'État et ne sert d'inspirer les
casseurs d'extrême gauche qui se
saisissent saisissent maintenant qui
saisit maintenant toutes les occasions
pour tenter d'instaurer un état de
non-droit dans notre pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Pierre Mauguin pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre samedi dernier plus
de 80 mères et de nombreux habitants
manifestés devant le pôle de santé de
Villenoy contre le risque de fermeture
de la maternité en effet en
Lot-et-Garonne comme dans de nombreuses
autres départements ruraux d'outre-mer
ou encore l'entrée en application de la
loi risque le 3 avril aura pour effet de
voir inéluctable une réduction voire la
fermeture de services d'urgence et de
maternité dans les hôpitaux
comme vous le savez le maintien de ces
services publics essentiels constituent
un enjeu majeur pour la santé et pour
les territoires concernés
les femmes enceintes sont souvent
contraintes de parcourir de longues
distances pour accéder à l'hôpital le
plus proche ne pas avoir la certitude de
pouvoir accoucher à proximité de son
domicile est extrêmement anxiogène
nous sommes en droit d'attendre de votre
part une réponse qui dépasse les
logiques comptables à l'origine de la
dégradation des services
je partage l'objectif fondamental de
plafonner la rémunération de l'intérim
médical qui s'apparente dans certains
cas à un chantage exercé sur le service
public de la santé au mépris des
principes humanistes de la médecine en
revanche l'application de cette loi peut
avoir des effets catastrophiques sur nos
petits hôpitaux
monsieur le ministre pensez-vous que les
habitants des zones rurales sont des
citoyens de seconde zone
quel signal comptez-vous leur envoyer
dans les prochains jours monsieur le
ministre quelle mesure urgente
envisagez-vous de prendre afin de
préserver en priorité nos maternités
rurales et nos services hospitaliers
avec vous avez vous l'intention
d'abaisser en zone rurale le seuil de
milieu naissance par an afin d'y
maintenir le maternité je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
Monsieur François Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Moga il y a bien entendu pas de
citoyens de seconde zone et mon travail
sur l'autorité de la première ministre
c'est de rétablir l'accès à la santé
équitable pour tous sur l'ensemble de
nos territoires vous évoquez deux
problèmes le premier concernant
l'intérim médical mais nous parlons bien
ici des dérives de cette intérim médical
et non de l'intérim qui est qui est
normal et qui fonctionne et qui permet
de maintenir justement ces petites
structures c'est dérives d'intérim
médical elles sont à court terme soyez
incertains la mort de notre service
public hospitalier quel médecin
acceptera encore de travailler pour 4000
euros par mois lorsqu'un intérimaire
venant 24 heures aura la même somme
par rapport à ces dérives de la dérive
médical il faut agir sur les deux
tableaux lutter contre les dérives et
aussi préserver cette colonne vertébrale
de notre système public hospitalier que
sont les médecins hospitaliers c'est
pourquoi nous agissons des deux côtés
tout d'abord la limitation de l'intérim
vous l'avez dit ensuite favoriser
l'exercice des médecins hospitaliers en
prolongeant les mesures de cet été ces
mesures qui permettent d'augmenter la
rémunération pour les comptes de
l'intérim il avait été défini en 2016
avec les évolutions depuis les
maintenant à 1390 euros brut par mois
concernant les petites maternités vous
évoquez par la notion de 1000 naissance
le rapport du professeur yvelville
rapport qu'il a fait à la demande et à
l'Académie de médecine c'est un rapport
fait par des scientifiques c'est un
rapport scientifique qui n'engage en
aucun cas bien entendu le gouvernement
ni mon ministère je vous rejoins dans la
volonté de maintenir ces unités de
proximité mais nous devons aussi réussir
à combiner sécurité qualité et proximité
c'est ce à quoi je m'y emploi je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Fabien
gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste la
parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre depuis une semaine le
débat public se concentre sur les
violences dans les manifestations
retraite elles doivent être condamnées
sans ambiguïté mais elles ne peuvent
détourner l'attention des vraies
questions la vraie question c'est
qu'après trois mois de mobilisation une
majorité de Français refuse toujours de
travailler deux ans de plus pour
satisfaire les marchés financiers la
vraie question c'est qu'après votre
passage en force au Parlement en
détournant des moyens constitutionnels
votre légitimité démocratique et
considérablement affaiblie la vraie
question c'est la répression syndicale
et les réquisition la répression du
mouvement social avec des nazes portant
interdites des arrestations arbitraires
des armes offensives qui blessent et
doivent être proscrites et la violence
policière de la bravenne révélée par des
enregistrements parus dans la presse et
qui doit être dissoute la vraie question
c'est que vous avez perdu toute autorité
politique
que vous êtes seul et que vous ne
renouez pas avec le pays en restant
confiné la vraie question c'est qu'hier
vous rayez une foule mais c'est un fait
un peuple qui se tient devant vous droit
digne fier calme et qui avec le
mouvement social univers assemblé veut
être respecté entendu madame la Première
ministre en politique il faut avoir des
convictions et les affirmer parfois
contre vents et marées mais lorsque vous
piétinez la démocratie sociale lorsque
vous humiliez le Parlement lorsque vous
risquez des drames par le choix de
l'autoritarisme c'est le signe qu'il ne
faut pas s'embêter l'audace en politique
c'est parfois reconnaître qu'on a eu
tort et renoncer notre pays a besoin de
sortir la crise sociale politique et
démocratique dans laquelle vous l'avez
plongé c'est le seul apaisement possible
et ils doivent venir de vous nous vous
proposons deux issues politiques le
retrait de la réforme ou le référendum
d'initiative partagée madame la première
ministre allez-vous enfin écouter et
respecter la majorité du peuple français
fondateur vous dites deux choses à
l'occasion de votre question la première
c'est que vous et je partage vous
condamnez les violences qui sont
commises en marge des manifestations et
c'est une manière je crois toujours vous
l'avez dit c'est une manière je crois de
partager l'hommage régulièrement rendu
par le gouvernement et singulièrement
parmi de l'Intérieur à l'action des
forces de police pour protéger les
cortèges et garder le maintien de
l'ordre et ensuite monsieur le sénateur
vous dites nous vous proposons deux
issues le référendum ou le retrait du
texte permettez-nous d'en emprunter une
troisième la troisième c'est celle du
dialogue social et de la reprise du
dialogue c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
première ministre a proposé à l'Inter
syndical de les recevoir dès le début de
la semaine prochaine pour travailler sur
les sujets d'usure professionnelle de
déroulement de carrière de bien-être au
travail c'est la raison pour laquelle
aussi monsieur le sénateur nous
souhaitons que l'ensemble des
initiatives prises par les partenaires
sociaux je pense notamment à la Cour
nationale interprofessionnelle sur le
partage de la valeur puisse aussi faire
l'objet de concertation de travail
commun pour qu'il puisse être transposés
par la loi le dialogue toujours le
dialogue et dépend toujours ouverte pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions
avancer merci
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Marie-Laure pineraor pour le
gros du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre samedi dernier la Guyane s'est
réveillé sous le choc Arnaud blanc
maréchal des logis chef de l'antenne
locale du GIGN a été tué lors d'une
opération de lutte contre leur paillage
illégal nos pensées d'ailleurs vont à sa
famille ses proches ainsi qu'à ses
frères d'armes ce drame intervient
quelques jours après que des hommes
armés de mitrailleuses kalachnikov ont
braqué un autre site d'orpaillage et on
pris en otage le personnel et un pilote
d'hélicoptère ces incidents sont les
conséquences d'une forte augmentation de
l'empaillage illégal mais aussi de la
présence de factions en provenance du
Brésil nous ne sommes pas au bout de nos
peines en effet depuis son investiture
le président Lula a déclaré la guerre à
leur paillage clandestin au Brésil ainsi
près de 20 000 garennes Perros ont été
chassés de la réserve yanomanie on
estime à 5000 le nombre d'empailleurs
illégaux qui pourraient ainsi rejoindre
la Guyane et porter à 11000 le
contingent de le chercheur d'or illégaux
sur notre territoire pour ne rien
arranger sur les marchés internationaux
le cours de l'or ne cesse de s'envoler
ces dernières semaines rendant les
sous-sols de la Guyane plus attractifs
que jamais vous connaissez monsieur le
ministre les enjeux environnementaux et
sécuritaires auxquels est confronté la
Guyane en 2017 le président de la
République lui-même avec conditionné nos
aides et nos relations diplomatiques
avec le Brésil et le Suriname à une
coopération policière et judiciaire
contre leur paillage illégal 6 ans plus
tard et malgré les opérations harpies
leur paillage illégal demeure un fléau
hors de contrôle c'est pourquoi monsieur
le ministre je souhaiterais connaître
précisément les mesures que vous
entendez prendre pour intensifier
l'action de l'État en matière de lutte
contre l'empaillage illégal préserver
l'intégrité du territoire guyanais
protéger les populations guyanaises et
préserver l'environnement je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste de l'intérieur et les
outre-mer monsieur Darmanin merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames etatrice
merci et je veux avoir comme vous au nom
de la première ministre du gouvernement
une pensée pour la famille et pour le
sacrifice du maréchal et le chef blanc
militaire du GIGN très rompu à
l'exercice et qui a trouvé effectivement
la mort sans doute assassiné l'enquête
le dira par ce que vous dénoncez
permettez-moi aussi d'avoir une pensée
pour les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris qui
connaissent au moment où je parle un
accident extrêmement grave de la route
en Guyane là aussi avec plusieurs
pronostics vital engagés je sais que je
parle au nord de la représentation
nationale en associant évidemment à je
veux dire madame la sénatrice que la
lutte de la France
contre leur paillage illégal est une
lutte pour la souveraineté bien sûr une
lutte contre les trafics de tout genre
et une lutte contre l'insécurité qui
touche de compatriotes guyanais vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est armée qui
pillent le sol de la Guyane qui pollue
parce que c'est la protection de
l'environnement qui est évidemment en
jeu mais qui ensuite revendent et
ensuite vont dans les villes de Guyane
et bien sûr à Cayenne mais pas
simplement faut aussi naître les
augmentations d'homicides et de
tentative de missiles que votre
collectivité connaît depuis trop
longtemps alors le gouvernement a
augmenté les moyens 250 policiers
gendarmes depuis six ans l'opération
Harpie civilo militaire gendarmerie
nationale mais également de l'armée je
parle aussi au nom bien sûr de Sébastien
Lecornu a été renouvelé sous le
président Hollande parce qu'elle avait
imaginé en 2008 et renouvelée ce
président Macron en 2018 et je sais
qu'autour de la première liste nous
réfléchissons à renforcer des moyens
notamment militaires dans le cas de la
loi de programmation militaire qui vous
sera bientôt proposé pour prendre en
compte le nouveau deal brésilien que
vous évoquez la protection de la plus
grande frontière qu'à la France a qu'un
pays étranger c'est-à-dire le Brésil
évidemment tenir la protection de la
forêt amazonienne avec toutes les
difficultés que nous connaissons le
sacrifice de militaire du GIGN ne n'est
pas 20 il est évidemment comme tous ces
autres camarades un soldat de la
protection de nos frontières de nos
compatriotes guyanais ce n'est pas
simplement pour protéger une forêt c'est
déjà beaucoup qui militaire du GIGN sont
dans la forêt amazonienne en Guyane
c'est pour protéger évidemment
l'aiguille à nez des règlements de
compte extrêmement nombreux que nous
connaissons depuis de trop nombreux mois
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Patrick pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre j'ai regardé attentivement les
dernières déclarations qui pouvaient
définir votre ligne politique depuis
l'échec de la réforme des retraites
entérinés par votre absence de majorité
sur ce texte
je retiens le nid d'isolution ni
remaniement ni référendum du président
de la République et votre proposition de
dialoguer la semaine prochaine avec les
syndicats mais sur les seuls sujets sur
lesquels vous êtes d'accord selon les
mots même de votre Ministre Franck
Riester
en vous mettant au service d'un
président de la République du triple ni
pour ne pas dire du déni vous êtes
devenu la première ministre de l'impasse
malgré toutes vos tentatives de
diversion malgré votre stratégie assumée
du pourrissement l'opposition à votre
réforme des retraites n'a jamais été
aussi massive parmi les Français le
mouvement social est le plus important
depuis des années 90 les syndicats
montrent depuis le début de cette
mobilisation leur grande responsabilité
en les traitant comme vous le faites
madame la Première ministre vous jouez
avec notre pacte républicain je ne veux
pas que vous noyer le poisson le poisson
en assinant au Sénat vos habituelles
élément de langage sur une réforme dite
indispensable pour sauver notre système
de retraite plus personne ne vous croit
et si vous évoquez l'actuel climat de
violence inacceptable qui a émaillé
certaines manifestations avec les
syndicats nous les avons dénoncés comme
nous l'avons toujours fait et nous aussi
mes chers collègues nous soutenons
l'ordre républicains et ceux qui le
défendent policier et gendarmes
mais nous avons le droit nous avons le
droit d'interroger la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre du gouvernement à
l'espèce ce que je veux madame la
Première ministre c'est que vous
répondiez à la proposition de la terre
syndicale que vous acceptiez la
médiation que vous suspendiez
l'application de cette réforme injuste
et inutile que vous preniez en compte la
réalité il n'est plus temps de jouer
avec les matamorphes jouer les
matamorphes comme le fait Emmanuel
Macron il est temps de répondre avec
sérieux aux demandes des syndicats je
vous offre une tribune profitez-en
quand vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Patrick Kanner
comme chacun ici qu'il se soit opposé à
la réforme des retraites ou qui les
votait je vais au contact des Français
j'entends leur crainte leurs espoirs et
parfois leur colère
comme chacun ici j'entends les
revendications de celles et ceux qui
prennent pas au mouvement social des
revendications qui dépassent la réforme
des retraites comme chacun ici je suis
attentive aux témoignages des élus
locaux qui sont en première ligne face
aux difficultés de nos concitoyens comme
chacun ici je connais les attentes des
Français pour leur pouvoir d'achat pour
leur santé pour l'éducation de leurs
enfants alors monsieur le Président
Kanner ma conviction aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il ne faut pas chercher à renforcer
les craintes qu'il ne faut pas chercher
à attiser les colères aujourd'hui il
faut apaiser le pays en rassemblant les
bonnes volontés toutes celles et ceux
au-delà des clivages qui sont prêts à
trouver des solutions aujourd'hui il ne
faut pas renoncer à agir au contraire il
faut accélérer apporter des réponses
concrètes qui améliorent le quotidien
des Françaises et des Français
c'est aujourd'hui autour de ces deux
axes que je souhaite bâtir dans les
prochaines semaines un programme de
gouvernement et un agenda législatif
comme le président de la République mon
a confié la tâche depuis lundi j'ai donc
entamé une série de consultations GVI
hier le président du Sénat et la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale je
l'ai poursuit avec les forces politiques
les parlementaires les élus locaux et
les partenaires sociaux que j'ai invités
à une rencontre en début de semaine
prochaine ma seule ambition c'est de
trouver des solutions au service des
Français et de bâtir des majorités de
projets pour les mettre en oeuvre toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent agir pour les
Français sont les bienvenus c'est de
cette manière par la concertation par le
dialogue et par le compromis que nous
répondrons aux inquiétudes de nos
compatriotes je remercie
monsieur le Président kaner quelques
secondes
monsieur le président
programme de gouvernement nous répond
Madame Elisabeth borne mais madame borne
ça fait 70 mois 70 mois que vous êtes au
pouvoir avec vos amis politiques vous
n'avez plus de boussole et surtout je le
pense très sincèrement vous ne comprenez
plus l'esprit des Français c'est ça qui
est terrible aujourd'hui dans notre pays
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Nathalie Delattre pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre monsieur le ministre de la
Santé mes chers collègues notre jeunesse
est en grande souffrance psychologique
de plus en plus de jeunes font face à un
état dépressif et certains vont jusqu'à
intenter à leurs jours et nous les
pleurons un nain pression sociale
pression des réseaux sociaux harcèlement
éco-anxiété crise sanitaire les crises
de ce mal-être sont multifactorielles
les séquences terribles le Haut Conseil
de la famille de l'enfance et de l'âge
vient de publier un rapport intitulé
quand les enfants vont mal comment les
aider les chiffres concernant la
consommation médicamenteuse son glaçons
chez les 6-17 ans un jeune sur deux
consomme des psychotropes en 8 ans cette
consommation a explosé plus 49%
d'antipsychotiques plus 55%
d'hypnotiques et sédatifs plus 63%
d'antidépresseurs ce phénomène de
surdécation ne concerne pas des cas
isolés mais bien des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants et place la France
parmi les pays les plus prescripteurs
des médicaments qui plus est pour
adultes car aucune médication de ce type
n'est autorisée sur le marché
aujourd'hui pour nos enfants la France
privilégie donc le traitement des
symptômes puisqu'elle est soudotée des
capacités à agir sur les racines du mal
car là est le cœur du problème la
psychiatrie le parent pauvre de la
médecine nous comptons seulement 600
pédopsychiatre auprès de 10 millions
d'enfants la Cour des comptes préconise
d'ailleurs de dresser l'état des lieux
de cette spécialité
800 médecins scolaires soit un médecin
pour 15000 élèves imaginez-vous l'état
de désemparement des parents qui se
battent corps et âme pour permettre à
leurs enfants d'avoir une assistance
psychologique quand on leur annonce que
pour obtenir une place dans un centre
médico-pédagogique qu'il faut attendre
deux ans oui 2 ans la France elle aussi
attend depuis des années son splend
psychiatrique financé madame la Première
ministre monsieur le ministre de la
Santé et les grands temps d'établir ce
plan budgétaire et d'oser ériger la
psychiatrie en grande cause nationale je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la santé et de la
prévention
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs USA madame la Présidente de
Lattre la santé mentale est une priorité
bien entendu et la santé mentale des
jeunes encore plus pour ce gouvernement
et que je partage avec mes collègues
Papen Diaz Sarah et lahery et Charlotte
cobel bien entendu nous ignorons rien
des difficultés de la pédopsychiatrie
difficulté qui sont pas nouvelles vous
avez rappelé le chiffre des
pédopsychiatres qui est bien insuffisant
mais je vous le rappelle qu'il faut 10
ans pour former un médecin ça va être
long on va pas régler le problème tout
de suite pour autant nous agissons quand
même nous agissons depuis la feuille de
route qui a été mise en place en 2018
renforcée en 2021 par les assises de la
santé mentale qu'est-ce qui a été fait
déjà le programme des 1000 premiers
jours qui permet un accompagnement
ensuite la mise en place des maisons des
adolescents il y a maintenant une Maison
des adolescents au minimum dans chaque
département il y a également des
structures qui se déploient pour aller
vers les jeunes dans nos zones rurales
qui sont le plus loin des des grandes
villes c'est en particulier le cas à
Poitiers avec un qui se déplace avec une
équipe de la Maison des adolescents et
puis il y a également le déploiement de
mon parcours psy on dit beaucoup de
choses sur mon parcours psy mais avec
plus de 300 000 consultations depuis que
cela a été créé dont 20% pour des jeunes
mineurs c'est un véritable succès sur
lequel il faut que nous construisions
aussi l'avenir j'attends dans les
prochaines semaines les conclusions des
Assises de la santé de l'enfant et de la
pédiatrie que j'ai lancé pendant la
crise de cet hiver dans ces assises il y
a un des 6 chapitres qui est entièrement
consacré à la pédopsychiatrie nous
aurons à construire ensemble et à
échanger sur la feuille de route pour la
pédopsychiatrie des prochaines années je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
dossier pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur le bilan de ce
qu'il s'est passé samedi à Sainte-Soline
est lourd je le sais j'y étais
et je l'assume deux manifestants dans le
coma entre la vie et la mort de ton
espère une sortie sans séquelle grave 47
blessés parmi les forces de l'ordre à
qui nous souhaitons évidemment un prompt
rétablissement de s'en blesser dans
certains mutilés parmi les manifestants
à qui nous souhaitons aussi un pro
rétablissement des violences un
qualifiables ce sont déchaînés et nous
les dénonçons toutes sans ambiguïté mais
c'est votre bilan du week-end monsieur
le ministre vous avez décidé à Sainte
Soline d'exposer 3000 forces de l'ordre
à la violence dans un champ pour
défendre quoi qu'il en coûte un trou un
trou vide vous avez décidé d'interdire
une manifestation totalement légitime
parce que vous êtes incapable de faire
respecter la loi en matière de partage
de l'eau oui de nombreuses bassines
déclarées illégales sont toujours en
construction et vous êtes incapable
d'assumer votre responsabilité oui la
bassine de s'insoline mais en danger la
ressource en eau de
territoire depuis trois jours vos
mensonges ont éclaté au grand jour des
armes de guerre ont bien été employés
samedi des brigades motorisées étaient
bien équipés de LBD des secours ont été
entravés et empêcher d'intervenir sur
hors de la gendarmerie des gaz
lacrymogènes ont été envoyés sur des sur
des blessés vous mentez comme vous avez
menti ici lors du fiasco du Stade de
France dans quel pays après avoir mis
deux manifestants dans le coma toute la
chaîne de commandement ne s'interroge
pas sur la méthode de maintien de
l'ordre dans quel pays après un tel
fiasco un ministre peut continuer de
mentir à répétition et petits un
collectif d'opposants politiques
pour répondre la parole est au ministre
de l'Intérieur et les outre-mer
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur le sénateurs monsieur
Saint-Georges je n'ai pas tout compris
de votre question
vous oui il y avait un peu de bruit mais
je crois que vous faisiez une différence
entre la gauche et le gauchisme
finalement dans votre intervention et je
regrette que des parlementaires
revendiquent d'aller dans une
manifestation illégale
ne respectant ainsi pas eux-mêmes la loi
de la République je regrette que des
parlementaires puissent être à côté de
ceux qui jettent des cocktails Molotov
sur des gendarmes
je regrette que des parlementaires
puissent ne pas constater comme j'ai pu
le constater de voir des gendarmes dont
les pieds eux-mêmes ont été attaqués par
l'acide je regrette monsieur le sénateur
que vous n'ayez pas entendu les deux
conférences faites de conférence de
presse faite par la préfète avant la
manifestation qui était interdite depuis
le 17 mars ni même celle du procureur de
la République manifestement vous êtes
assis sur tout ça sur les violences
contre nos gendarmes sur l'interdiction
de manifestation sur les conférences de
la préfète de la République sur la
conférence du procureur de la République
je regrette par ailleurs que vous
relayez ici de nouveau des fake news non
monsieur le sénateur les secours n'ont
pas été empêchés par les forces de
l'ordre oui mais écoutez le SAMU
regarder le CMU le salut des Deux-Sèvres
qui le dit lui-même je sais que ça vous
ferait plaisir de penser que les
gendarmes souhaitent la mort des gens
mais ce n'est pas le cas
c'est le médecin du GIGN monsieur le
sénateur qui a fondu la foule alors
qu'il a été harcelé par manifestement
vos camarades d'un jour mais vous pouvez
hocher la tête c'est extrêmement
scandaleux ce qui se passe et les poules
et les gendarmes eux-mêmes ont dû faire
demi-tour parce qu'alors qu'ils allaient
secourir à manifestant il se faisait
harceler par des pluies de pavés et de
cocktail Molotov voilà la vérité
monsieur le sénateur
et moi aussi je vais avoir une pensée
bien sûr pour toute personne qui a été
blessée manifestement pour ceux qui
luttent pour la vie et l'enquête
judiciaire dira ce qu'elle dira la
vérité et je suis évidemment prêt avec
tous les administrations pour y répondre
j'ai dit au président de la commission
des lois que j'étais à sa disposition
comme à l'Assemblée nationale pour
répondre à vos questions mais il y a un
truc il y a une chose conclure il y a
une chose Monsieur le Président pardon
je ne ferai pas c'est cracher comme vous
le faites sur la tête des forces de
l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur j'assume ma présence j'assume
évidemment ma présence j'assume ma
mission de contrôle du gouvernement vous
ne pourrez pas organiser une
manifestation à huit clos vous ne
pourrez pas éborgner à huis clos mais
vous êtes le ministre d'un pays où le
président ne peut plus sortir de son
palais vous êtes le ministre d'un
gouvernement
vous êtes le ministre d'un pays bloqué
fracturé par votre autoritarisme
vous vous copiez terminé
la parole est à Madame Laurence Garnier
pour le groupe les républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Olivier Véran ministre en
charge du renouveau démocratique
monsieur le ministre en 2021 les
violences contre les mers et les élus
ont augmenté de 47% en 2022 elles ont à
nouveau augmenté de 32% donc en deux ans
ces violences ont presque doublé alors
il s'agit d'insultes d'agression mais
aussi désormais d'actes criminels la
semaine dernière la voiture et la maison
du maire de Saint-Brévin en
Loire-Atlantique ont été touchés par un
incendie volontaire
monsieur le ministre c'est violence
seule leurs auteurs en sont responsables
mais les élus locaux payent aujourd'hui
un climat de défiance que vous avez
contribué à aggraver je rappelle qu'en
2018 l'actuel ministre de l'Intérieur a
publié la liste des maires augmentant la
taxe d'habitation
c'en est suivie la campagne de
dénigrement balance ton air orchestré
par les militants de votre mouvement
politique
monsieur le ministre vous semblez avoir
aujourd'hui pris la mesure de la
situation les mesures et les derniers
textes de loi adopter vont dans le bon
sens mais le remède court après le mal
de nombreuses plaintes restent classées
sans suite les agressions se poursuivent
souvent dans la plus grande impunité
monsieur le ministre avant de vous
lancer dans le renouveau démocratique
dont vous avez la charge comment
allez-vous protéger ceux qui font vivre
notre République au quotidien dans les
35 000 communes de France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique et porte parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Laurence Garnier je
vous remercie de m'interpeller
communiste délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique au sujet des violences dans
son victime de plus souvent et de plus
en plus souvent les élus de la
République vous dire d'abord je partage
votre émotion et votre colère face à des
actes de violence qui s'accentue et qui
deviennent de plus en plus nombreux on
va avoir une divergence sur le
diagnostic madame la sénatrice parce que
quand on regarde l'histoire l'histoire
contemporaine française mais aussi
l'histoire occidentale en général on
voit que les élus commencent à être pris
pour cible par les populations
lorsqu'elles sont en colère depuis une
vingtaine d'années en réalité et il y a
un phénomène qui tente à sa croître on
peut y voir plusieurs continuums
probablement une forme de continuum
entre la violence anonyme et sans
conséquence des réseaux sociaux et la
violence qui peut s'exprimer dans la rue
ou lors de conseils municipaux on peut y
voir un continuum entre audience qui
parfois s'exprime au sein même de la
Maison du Peuple au sein même du
Parlement je parle essentiellement de
l'Assemblée nationale on l'a vu au cours
des dernières semaines et la violence
qui peut s'exprimer dans la rue nous
devons faire figure d'exemples nous
devons faire bloc pour montrer aux
Français que si nous pouvons partager
des divergences et des logiques
profondes si nous pouvons être en
désaccord profond sur certaines lois
certaines mesures en aucun cas nous ne
perdons le respect de l'autre en aucun
cas nous ne perdons l'estime pour
l'autre madame la sénatrice il se trouve
que j'ai contacté quelques heures après
l'incendie le maire Yannick Morez quelle
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins parce que
j'avais été profondément ému de
constater alors il y aura une enquête
pour pouvoir le démontrer mais que du
simple fait qu'il est accepté la mise en
place d'un centre d'accueil pour
réfugier à la demande d'ailleurs de
l'État et c'est son rôle de la suscepté
il a été d'abord victime de menaces de
mort d'injures puis finalement à vue son
domicile dégradé avec l'incendie de ces
deux voitures et dégradations d'une
partie de sa maison par vous dites par
qui madame la sénatrice cette fois-ci
c'est probablement extrême droite madame
laissa triste mais madame la sénatrice
je vais vous dire une chose je vais vous
dire une chose l'ennemi de la République
c'est l'extrême c'est la radicalité
quand elle s'exprime qu'elle soit de
gauche ou de droite l'ultra droite et
l'ultra gauche sont les ennemis que nous
combattons et que nous devons combattre
et vous ne verrez jamais d'ambiguïté
vous ne verrez jamais d'envievalence et
vous ne verrez jamais de oui mais
lorsqu'il s'agit de condamner des
violences retirer le mets retirez le
main après les oui et ensuite vous aurez
des leçons madame la sénatrice madame la
sénatrice pour terminer vous dire que
nous devons faire ce travail pédagogique
pour aller expliquer aux populations que
nous devons protéger les mers ils font
partie de la Villa nation et s'attaquer
à ma mère c'est s'attaquer à la s'il
vous plaît
madame Garnier vous avez quelques
secondes
oui merci monsieur le ministre pour vous
répondre ce qu'on voit tous c'est que
les Français votent de moins en moins et
que les élus se font agresser de plus en
plus donc je crois effectivement que
nous devons tous ensemble résoudre cette
crise démocratique que nous traversons
[Applaudissements]
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
tout le monde ici condamne les violences
d'où qu'elles viennent et quel qu'en
soit les victimes manifestants force de
l'ordre dont nous avons salué
l'engagement nous sommes le saluons
encore à l'instant c'est pourquoi
l'effet commis par la brave la semaine
dernière à Paris sont inacceptables
Valentin 19 ans je suis projeté au sol
une moto me roule sur la jambe gauche et
ma tombe de 56 cm
soulaymane 23 ans tu as tellement de
chance d'être assis là je te jure je te
pétais les jambes au sens propre je peux
te dire qu'on en a cassé des coudes et
des gueules Salomé 22 ans ta vie ne
tient qu'à un fil je vois la peur dans
ton regard j'aime ça Paul Boyer
journaliste 25 ans sans un mot un agent
de la brave le frappe au visage avec une
matraque traumatisme crânien fracture de
la main gauche alors monsieur le
ministre vous engagez-vous ici
aujourd'hui à adressé à l'ensemble des
forces de l'ordre la lettre du 29 mai
1968 de Maurice Grimaud préfet de police
de Paris qui disait nous n'avons pas le
droit de passer sous silence les excès
dans l'emploi de la force frapper un
manifestant à terre c'est se frapper
soi-même en apparaissant sous un jour
qui atteint toute la fonction policière
vous devez faire une guerre impitoyable
à tous ceux qui parlent leurs actes
inconsidérés à crédit très l'image
déplaisante que l'on cherche à donner de
nous
pour vous répondre la parole est comme
ils disent de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
merci Monsieur Président Mesdames et
Messieurs 7h madame la sénatrice qui est
comme dans toute profession comme dans
toute activité des policiers des
gendarmes qui ne respectent pas les
valeurs le droit la déontologie c'est
une évidence et d'ailleurs j'en ai
sanctionné plus que la moyenne lorsque
vous étiez en responsabilité de
quinquennat d'avant vous avez connu les
périodes de les manifestations étaient
difficiles je pense à la loi travail de
Madame Connery ou des difficultés de
maintien de l'ordre je pense à Sylvain
ce que vous citez peu finalement
dernièrement dans les interventions du
groupe socialiste
et oui madame la sénatrice j'ai
sanctionné et j'ai parfois fait retirer
l'uniforme des policiers des gendarmes
parce qu'ils doivent être exemplaires
mais je ne serai jamais dans la
démagogie comme vous l'êtes madame la
sénatrice qui consiste à comparer de
manière équitable les violences de la
police je mets des guillemets des
violences des casseurs parce que quand
on met un trait égal quand on dit
violence policière ils ont des casseurs
on a l'impression finalement tout ça est
un conflit et que il y a des deux côtés
des gens qui mériteraient effectivement
à l'égalité le Parti socialiste a oublié
que les morceaux le Parti socialiste a
oublié monsieur Cazeneuve le Parti
socialiste oblige monsieur Badinter je
ne rappelle pas du maintien de l'ordre
évidemment que vous avez mis en place
vous-même que nous on a corrigé parce
que c'est nous qui avons présenté au
Conseil d'État schéma de matelas qui a
été validé madame la sénatrice en disant
des oui mais
vous répondez au vieil étage de ma
grand-mère qui était fan de mineur ma
grand-mère me disait quand on dit oui
mais c'est que la phrase
bien sûr bien sûr on a tous compris que
vous aviez un grand problème avec la
nuit peste pour soutenir les forces de
l'ordre et chacun le voit chacun le voit
dans l'opinion de la République les
policiers ne veulent pas de 8 mai oui il
y a de l'exigence mais ils veulent du
soutien parce que ce sont des femmes et
des hommes fort mal payés
malheureusement qui protège nos
concitoyens et comme hier ils l'ont
démontré permet à chacun de manifester
dans de bonnes conditions le procès que
vous faites madame la sénatrice et là
encore je suis prêt à répondre assez
longuement quand il voudra au présent de
la commission des lois aux policiers de
la République n'est pas digne d'un grand
parti du gouvernement comme le vôtre
madame de la grande
monsieur le Président je voudrais dire
au ministre de l'Intérieur quatre
ministres de l'Intérieur ce n'est pas
seulement être le ministre de la police
mais vous êtes en charge de la paix
civile donc vous devez non seulement
défendre les policiers et les gendarmes
et vous devez veiller au respect de
l'État de droit c'est ce que les
Français attendent le respect de l'ordre
mais dans la justice et puisque vous
vous référer à des grands ministres de
l'intérieur de gauche permettez-moi de
me référer à Pierre Joxe avec qui j'ai
eu l'honneur de travailler au ministère
de l'intérieur d'une part plan
quinquennal de modernisation de la
police d'autre part création de la
Direction de la Formation
instauration du code de déontologie
Déclaration des droits de l'homme dans
les commissariats voilà le modèle que
vous devriez suivre
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
crémier pour le groupe les républicains
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
les négociations européennes sont
totalement défavorables et énergie
nucléaires c'est grave
s'éternir Jean a été intégrée à la
taxonomie verte qu'au prix de conditions
drastiques pour preuve les autorisations
délivrées après 2040 2045 en sont exclus
de même que les activités de maintenance
et du cycle aujourd'hui la directive ENR
3 et le règlement industrie à 0 et
mission l'exclut également elle a
réforme du marché d'électricité est
toujours en attente c'est un non sens
pour le climat car cette énergie
n’aimait que 6 g de CO2 par
kilowattheure selon l'étude de la dame
c'est un non sens pour l'industrie car
la moitié des États membres dispose d'un
parc nucléaire et un cas remisage de
nouveau réacteurs c'est un manque cruel
de crédibilité car il est illusoire des
carboner 75% de l'hydrogène dans
l'industrie ou 5% dans les transports
sans source nucléaires le gouvernement
n'a pas conduit la politique à la
hauteur des enjeux c'est une faute il
aurait fallu moitié plus presque
aussiment plus fortement pour parvenir
un compromis admissible je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le Sénat a tiré le signal
d'alarme depuis longtemps à travers sa
résolution de décembre 2021 sur la taxe
de l'univers verte et celle de mars 2022
sur le paquet ajustement 55 c'est aussi
un coin d'alerte de son rapport
transpartisan de juillet dernier
Monsieur le Ministre que compte faire le
gouvernement pour obtenir enfin
satisfaction auprès de ses partenaires
européens y a-t-il encore un couple
franco-allemand il faut garantir à
l'énergie et à l'hydrogène nucléaire une
complète neutralité technologique il en
va de notre souveraineté énergétique et
de nous engagements climatiques
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués en charge de
l'Industrie monsieur Lescure
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gréminier d'abord je voudrais
vous remercier pour l'engagement que
vous avez eu depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années vous avez fait
référence à certaines dispositions
adoptées par le Sénat mais plus
récemment aussi en tant que rapporteur
du projet de loi présenté par le
gouvernement pour l'accélérer la mise en
œuvre des projets nucléaires que nous
avons qui a été voté par cette assemblée
par plus de 9 sénateurs sur 10 ce même
projet de loi a été voté la semaine
dernière par l'Assemblée
7,5 donc 75% des députés l'ont voté
montrant que l'Union nationale derrière
le nucléaire ce qui n'a pas été tout le
temps le cas et aujourd'hui de mise en
France cette union nationale elle nous
permet de porter haut la voix de la
France en Europe et de négocier ou
l'avait dit avec difficulté l'engagement
de l'Europe qui doit reconnaître le
nucléaire comme une des sources
d'énergie de l'avenir vous le savez la
France ne fait pas tout toute seule en
Europe nous sommes 27 aujourd'hui ce que
je peux vous dire c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle je vous réponds et
non pas la ministre de la transition
énergétique qui était à Bruxelles hier
et qui est à Berlin aujourd'hui nous
continuons ces négociations hier la
ministre était avec ce qu'on appelle
l'alliance du nucléaire 11 pays qui en
Europe défendent le nucléaire comme une
source d'avenir qui sont aujourd'hui
alliés avec la France et qui sont prêtes
à bloquer un certain nombre de
discussions pour s'assurer que nucléaire
fera partie du futur nous avons vous
avez parlé du couple franco-allemand je
dirais un tango un peu difficile à mener
avec eux c'est vrai ils ont la
conviction que l'hydrogène de demain
sera importée et renouvelable nous
sommes convaincus que l'hydrogène de
demain il sera produit en France et
nucléaire nous devons trouver un
compromis nous avons besoin d'énormément
d'hydrogène pour décarboner l'industrie
nous allons continuer à travailler dans
ce sens et merci franchement sincèrement
au Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale de
son soutien du gouvernement dans ce
combat donc il faut le reconnaître qu'il
est difficile mais que nous allons mener
et gagner merci
monsieur gremier
oui monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui la
France souffre on est en pleine crise
énergétique au niveau des familles au
niveau des collectivités des entreprises
aujourd'hui on est devant un défi au
niveau de l'emploi nous ne réussirons de
nouveaux nucléaires que si nous
intéressons des jeunes nous sommes dans
le doute monsieur le ministre il y a un
véritable défi celui de l'article 184 du
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne qui
précise que chaque État membre a le
droit de choisir son mix énergétique
aujourd'hui la France est bafouée la
France n'est plus respectée au niveau de
ses choix stratégiques pour notre pays
merci
[Musique]
ma parole est à notre collègue Jean
agréé pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse à ministre à Madame
la Ministre de la Recherche de
l'enseignement supérieur depuis le début
de ce mouvement social hostile à la
réforme des retraites des dizaines de
lycées et d'universités ont été
paralysés même la faculté d'Assas
pourtant réputé la plus conservatrice de
France a été également bloquée et cela
pour la première fois de son histoire
votre gouvernement aura
incontestablement réussi quelque chose
dans cette douloureuse réforme faire
parvir d'envie Dani le rouge
la grève le blocage la manifestation
deviendra deviendrait presque un risque
initiatique dans notre pays chaque
génération veut sa grande mobilisation
chaque génération veut son mai 68
au-delà de ces manifestations se cachent
la précarité et le mal-être des
étudiants c'est pourquoi madame la
ministre mes interrogations sont
multiples que comptez-vous faire pour
empêcher une minorité de bloquer la
majorité que comptez-vous faire pour que
les examens se déroulent dans de bonnes
conditions que comptez-vous faire pour
les étudiants qui attendent des mesures
concrètes pour améliorer leur quotidien
pour vous répondre la parole d'État la
méduse de l'entraînement supérieur et de
la Recherche madame Retailleau
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jean ingrez alors tout d'abord
effectivement vous l'avez une partie des
universités sont bloqués aujourd'hui
quelques dizaines sur les 200
universités et écoles avec quelques
campus mais aussi des universités qui
connaissent des blocages avant les
manifestations et qui sont très relayées
je voudrais signaler et dire redire mais
vous le savez que l'université est aussi
d'abord un lieu de d'émancipation et des
changes mais aussi de confrontation des
idées je voudrais on le partage si les
jeunes n'exprimaient pas leurs idées je
pense qu'on craindrait pour notre
démocratie pour autant et pour autant le
côté de blocage même temporaire
d'empêcher les étudiants d'accepter à
leurs études ce n'est pas acceptable
mais il faut le savoir ce n'est pas la
panache uniquement des étudiants je
voudrais saluer la gestion du blocage à
travers les recteurs et les préfets des
régions et au travers de la gestion par
les présidents d'universités alors cela
m'emmène à répondre à vos différentes
questions et merci parce que aujourd'hui
effectivement effectivement la précarité
d'étudiants les étudiants parlent de
beaucoup de choses dans les
revendications et en particulier de
leurs conditions d'études et je vous
annonce donc aujourd'hui après des
concertations que nous menons depuis le
7 octobre au niveau national et au
niveau territorial avec l'ensemble des
acteurs le gouvernement et sur la
feuille de route du président de la
République a débloqué un demi milliards
d'euros 500 millions d'euros pour
répondre à la vie étudiante à la gestion
des bourses étudiantes et la rentrée
2023 mais aussi à la pérennisation du
repas en euros pour tous les boursiers
et tous les étudiants précaires et
d'autres mesures sur la vie étudiante
notre gouvernement le président de la
République et sur la feuille de route de
madame la Première ministre travaille
pour donner des conditions des bonnes
conditions à tous nos étudiants est-ce
que ce que nous allons faire dès la
rentrée 2023 c'est un des dispositifs et
des mesures historiques avec une
augmentation d'environ 20% sur les
bourses de nos étudiants et sur les
conditions de vie de nos étudiants voilà
la réponse que je peux vous faire
aujourd'hui
oui très bien merci madame la ministre
je pense que cette annonce régira les
bancs du Cénac que ce soit des bandes de
droite ou de la gauche puisque ce sont
des demandes que nous faisons de depuis
très longtemps l'augmentation des
bourses dans une semaine nous
proposerons avec mon collègue amis
Pierre-Antoine Lévin proposition de loi
notamment sur les repas étudiants à
tarif modéré dans les zones rurales les
zones de montagne aussi dans les petites
villes donc nous espérons que dans ces
500 millions vous pourrez intégrer une
partie du conventionnement avec les
CROUS en tout cas nous sommes vraiment
très heureux de ces annonces qui
j'espère contribuera à atténuer la
précarité et le mal-être étudiant même
si ce n'est jamais assez on peut se
réjouir au moins aujourd'hui de cette
bonne nouvelle
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Alain Cadec pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre la
France gronde et les marins pêcheurs
sont en colère
à une période où le prix du gasoil ne
cesse d'augmenter après un plan de
sortie de flotte qui est pénalise notre
capacité de pêche après la proposition
de la Commission européenne d'interdire
les arts traînants c'est à dire salut et
drague dans les aires marines protégées
voilà que le Conseil d'État saisi par
trois associations vous ordonne de
fermer des zones de pêche dans le golfe
de Gascogne afin de protéger les
dauphins dans la mortalité serait due à
des captures accidentelles cela fait
beaucoup je dirais même beaucoup trop en
effet si on additionne ces mesures
autant dire clairement qu'on abandonne
l'idée de préserver une activité
nécessaire à ce que tout le monde
souhaite une relative souveraineté
alimentaire le plan de sortie de flotte
augmente encore un peu plus notre
dépendance aux importations alors que
nous en sommes déjà 70% de produits de
la mer importée
par ailleurs s'agissant de la fin
programmée par les ONG et la Commission
européenne des arts traînants la
conséquence de cette mesure sera la
disparition pure et simple de la pêche
côtière plus de poissons plus de
poissons frais sur les étals plus de
coquilles Saint-Jacques par exemple dans
la gestion est exemplaire
vous fait sourire la coquille en tous
les cas sa gestion est exemplaire par la
préservation de sa ressource
ces décisions
ubuesque vont nous condamner à importer
davantage et à consommer de produits
surgelés c'est inacceptable s'agissant
des mesures de protection des cétacés il
existe déjà des dispositifs de
dissuasion acoustique pour ces espèces
dans l'efficacité n'est plus à démontrer
précisons au passage que les populations
de dauphins sont en augmentation
constante alors monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire face à ce déferlement
de contraintes et d'interdiction qui à
terme condamnera une activité porteuse
d'emploi qui n'a jamais été aussi
encadré et aussi vertueuse
pour vous répondre la parole est au
bilisent de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur fedo
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cadec merci de votre question
il me revient de vous répondre puisque
comme vous le savez ou comme il vous l'a
peut-être dire viberville est en
déplacement lui-même auprès des pêcheurs
en Vendée d'abord vous faire part comme
vous l'avez dit de la vous avez évoqué
la colère des pêcheurs et les forts
légitimes devant une décision une
proposition de la Commission européenne
qui les a interdire certaines techniques
de pêche dans des aires maritimes
protégées et qui s'apparente à un coup
de massue elle balaye cette décision ou
cette proposition d'un revers de main
tous les efforts qui ont pourtant montré
leur capacité à être productives pour à
la fois combiner les effets les
nécessités d'activité économique mais
aussi la préservation des habitats
marins le gouvernement a annoncé dès le
8 mars au Sénat c'était ici donc
l'opposition de la France à ce texte et
nous sommes les premiers à l'avoir fait
nous sommes désormais rejoints par un
certain nombre de pays l'important c'est
d'avoir une coalition pour faire face et
donner pièces à cette proposition
deuxième élément c'est ce que nous
faisons pour essayer de donner aussi une
perspective à la filière à la filière
pêche et aux pêcheurs le président de la
République et la première sont rappelées
lors du salon de l'agriculture mais en
place d'un fond de 130 millions d'euros
pour le secteur avec les aides carburant
à la fin de l'année dernière à Bruxelles
le gouvernement par la voie d'Hervé
d'erville a défendu face à la commission
toutes les façades maritimes françaises
pour maintenir les quotas de pêche et
les rendre plus réelle pour donner enfin
de la visibilité au pêcheur et nous
soutiendrons la réduction de la
dépendance au gazole des navires de
pêche et c'est ce que nous entendons
faire enfin je le dis c'est une filière
qui est une filière clé vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le sénateur nous
croyons comme vous dans cette filière
qui fait partie aussi de l'identité
française la pêche maritime française
est indispensable indispensable aussi
pour notre souveraineté c'est donc sur
ce chemin là que nous essayons d'avancer
à la fois face à des décisions de la
commission qui paraissent
incompréhensible et à la flamme en des
plans de soutien qui sont portés par le
ministre Hervé Berville et qui est tout
à fait aux côtés des pêcheurs malgré les
difficultés que nous rencontrons merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Thierry cosy pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain merci
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de l'économie et
j'y associe mon collègue Rachid themal
depuis l'an dernier l'inflation n'en
finit plus de ne plus finir les prix des
produits alimentaires ont grimpé de 14,5
% en un an et une nouvelle hausse de 10%
est à prévoir ces deux prochains mois ce
chiffre est en effet le plus élevé
depuis 1985 face à cela quelles réponses
vous apportez aux Français vous demandez
aux enseignes de pratiquer pendant trois
mois je cite les prix les plus bas
possible sur un ensemble de produits
leur choix je suis sceptique quant à la
crédibilité accordée à ce genre de
déclaration qui traduisent plus un voeu
pieux que l'institution d'une mesure
concrète cette volonté de rien imposer
au distributeur est incompréhensible car
de la veut même de la BCE une grande
partie de l'inflation serait tirée par
la volonté des entreprises de
sauvegarder leurs marges afin de
maintenir leur profit
le candidat Macron nous parlait de
mettre en place pour les ménages les
plus modestes un chèque alimentaire ma
question est donc simple quels
engagement comptez-vous prendre devant
la représentation nationale afin de
donner un cap lisible éclair pour nos
concitoyens un cap qui ne soit pas
l'otage de vos revirements incessants et
vous renoncements permanents un cap que
vous devez à nos concitoyens tant la
situation est difficile pour les plus
précaires d'entre eux
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des petites
des moyennes entreprises
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur cosy que vous parlez de
revirement qu'elle revirement
quel revirement quand depuis octobre
le président de la République Jean
Castex à l'époque puis Elisabeth borne
engage 110 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir les factures d'électricité de
nos concitoyens pas impayés européen n'a
autant soutenu le pouvoir d'achat mais
si on peut être en désaccord sur
beaucoup de choses mais pas là dessus
110 milliards d'euros c'est pas de la
flûte monsieur je vous réponds il y a au
moins le respect de m'écouter ce serait
sympathique 110 milliards d'euros ça se
vérifie 46 milliards 46 milliards jus
sur l'année 2023 pour accompagner les
factures d'énergie
alors excuse-moi et j'ai encore la
liberté de regarder où je veux oui merci
non suivez je vous remercie donc ce
gouvernement n'a jamais eu de revirement
en matière de soutien au pouvoir d'achat
vous le savez très bien et le soutien il
est massif et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
voté ici aux côtés des Français ensuite
vous critiquez avec force le trimestre
anti-inflation que nous avons mis en
place avec la grande distribution c'est
la première fois et vous le savez pour
connaître ces sujets monsieur le
sénateur cosy que la grande distribution
de façon unanime s'engage sur trois mois
vous savez très bien qu'en général les
promotions c'est deux à 15 jours de
promotion troisième engagement au-delà
d'être engagement rapide et collectif
cet engagement il est juste il prenne
sur leur marge pour assurer que les prix
n'augmentent pas avec Bruno Le Maire
nous avons donc beaucoup travaillé avec
eux durant trois mois ce trimestre
anti-inflation propose des centaines de
produits à nos compatriotes la direction
générale de la répression des fraudes et
de la concurrence surveille d'ailleurs
aux côtés des distributeurs que les
marges sont bien prises les efforts sont
bien faits sur les marges de dis
tributeurs et nous avons appelé avec
Bruno Le Maire à ce que il y est
possiblement une nouvelle négociation
pour faire baisser les prix s'il
continue à baisser le prix des matières
premières au printemps au mois de mai
avec les industriels alors aucun
revirement de la volonté de la
détermination et une inflation qui au
globale demeure l'une des plus faibles
d'Europe je vous remercie monsieur Cosic
madame la ministre les Français ont
besoin de stabilité chaque alimentaire
abandonné panier anti-inflation
abandonnés à la fin je crains que ce
soit les Français qui soient abandonnés
avec vos dispositifs montés comme une
usine à gaz c'est 50 nuances de prix
dans un panier percé avec l'abandon du
panier inflation vous placez le pays
dans les mains de la grande distribution
dont les marges ne faiblissent pas tout
en faisant passer ces dernières comme
les principaux acteurs de la lutte
contre la vie chère la République en
marche se mue en la République en marge
si à la fin ce n'était pas le
consommateur qui payait tous vos
revirements
la parole est à notre collègue Corinne
Imbert pour le gros plaie républicain
merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la santé et de la prévention
et j'associe à cette question mais de
collègues Marie Pierre Riché et Bruno
Belin monsieur le ministre je souhaitais
vous interroger sur le projet de décret
relatif au conditions de transfert et de
regroupement des officines de pharmacie
qui prévoiaient de définir des
territoires fragiles au sein desquels
l'accès aux médicaments pour la
population n'est pas assurée de manière
satisfaisante alors même que nous savons
que
99,5% de la population française habite
à moins de 15 minutes d'une pharmacie ce
projet de décrète proposerait deux
critères pour sélectionner ces
territoires sachant que les pharmacies
exploitées par un seul pharmacien
titulaire de plus de 65 ans serait issu
du calcul comme si aujourd'hui il ne
remplissait pas leur mission alors
pourquoi les écarter sauf à vouloir
peut-être récupérer la licence pour
faciliter un transfert une installation
dans une zone plus peuplée monsieur le
ministre où on est ce projet de décret
du territoire fragile en matière de
transfert de piscine jusqu'à quel niveau
le pouvoir des agences régionales de
santé sera-t-il élargi en matière
d'autorisation de transfert et de
regroupement d'officine et surtout
monsieur ministre que faites-vous de
l'aménagement du territoire et de la
prise en compte du maillage existant
de la parole est communiste de la santé
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs et sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
21000 officines couvre actuellement le
territoire national ce sont souvent dans
certains territoires le premier recours
un professionnel de santé ce sont les
plus visibles et je tiens vraiment ici à
les saluer ils tiennent cette première
ligne dans de nombreux territoires et
ils ont assuré leur fonction pendant la
crise sanitaire et encore de façon
quotidienne pour autant même si comme
vous le dites l'immense majorité du
territoire est couvert pour autant il
existe encore des territoires je pense à
la Corse je pense à la Guyane ou 18% de
nos concitoyens sont trop loin d'une
pharmacie c'est un peu le cas aussi sur
certains territoires dans le Grand Est
ce que je connais bien mais aussi dans
le dans le centre Val de Loire donc la
situation n'est pas totalement
satisfaisante même si globalement on a
une vision tout à fait correcte alors
c'est l'ordonnance du 3 janvier 2018 qui
propose donc ce décret et qui propose de
faire une adaptation territoire par
territoire c'est tout l'esprit de la
réforme du système de santé que nous
portons aujourd'hui c'est aussi tout
l'esprit des CNR santé territoriaux qui
ont été mis en place dans une logique de
dialogue territorial avec les
professionnels de santé concernés avec
les élus et avec les citoyens dans cette
logique nous sommes encore en train
d'élaborer des critères pour que ce
décret soit le plus opérationnel
possible il y a des critères de distance
mais il y a également des critères
populationnels en particulier des
territoires où il y aurait beaucoup de
personnes âgées qui n'auraient pas de
moyens de se déplacer c'est donc
vraiment du travail de dentellière
territoire par territoire qu'il va
falloir faire c'est pour ça que ce
décret est bientôt fini il est encore en
cours d'élaboration on ne s'interdit
rien et je discute avec les
représentants des pharmaciens pour que
vraiment ils puissent répondre à ses
citoyens qui sont encore trop loin d'une
réponse de pharmacie je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre pour
l'hommage que vous avez rendu au
pharmacien d'officine qui effectivement
font partie des professionnels de santé
en première ligne vous avez cité 28 000
officines ça fait -4000 officines depuis
quelques années vous n'y êtes pour rien
mais ça peut être un état c'est un état
de fait le problème c'est que il y a une
contradiction entre cette volonté ce qui
motiverait la rédaction de ce décret
pour répondre à quelques situations que
vous avez exposées et ces conséquences
qui conduiront à déstabiliser ce qui est
aujourd'hui un exemple en matière
d'aménagement du territoire les
officines de formation représentent une
vraie colonne vertébrale en matière
d'accès aux soins en matière
d'aménagement du territoire et vous
savez et vous ne l'ignorez pas et c'est
ce décret qui ne devrait pas fragiliser
l'existant aujourd'hui nombreux Français
vivent dans des déserts médicaux je vous
en supplie Monsieur le Ministre il
devient Jean de ne pas y ajouter des
déserts pharmaceutiques si vous
déstabilisez le réseau vous allez vous
allez comment dire nuire au patient et
favoriser non seulement peut-être des
gros investisseurs mais s'il vous plaît
monsieur le Président une fois de plus
vous allez sacrifier l'aménagement du
territoire et évidemment le monde rural
et ça ça serait pas acceptable je vous
remercie
la parole
est à notre collègue Patrick chaise pour
le groupe des Républicains
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
législateur a confié à la poste 4
missions de service public dont la
contribution à l'aménagement du
territoire celle-ci se traduit par
l'obligation de maintenir un réseau de
17000 points de contact ce qui garantit
une densité du réseau postal
spécifiquement française le 15 février
dernier l'état l'AMF et la Poste ont
signé le sixième contrat de présence
postale territoriale pour la période
2023 2025 celui-ci fixe le cadre
permettant à la pose de contribuer à la
mission d'aménagement du territoire il
prévoit les règles d'adaptation de son
réseau et de gestion du fonds de
péréquation territoriale d'un montant
annuel de 174 millions d'euros il doit
bénéficier prioritairement aux zones qui
en ont le plus besoin
face à une fréquentation en chute libre
des bureaux de poste la mutualisation
des réseaux territoriaux de la Poste et
de l'État est une condition de survie
selon le contrat mais en 2021 le coût du
maintien d'un maillage territorial fin
du service postal a été évalué par la
recette à 348 millions d'euros tandis
que la compensation reçue n'a été que de
la moitié cette sous-compensation risque
d'être très pénalisante en nous
permettant plus d'accomplir les
investissements utiles je tiens à
préciser que la gestion de ces crédits
est largement décentralisée et
déconcentré pour un pilotage réactif et
agile des projets conçus au plus près du
terrain par l'intermédiaire des CDPP
alors Monsieur le Ministre quelle mesure
le Gouvernement entend-il prendre pour
remédier à cette sous-compensation et
faire que la qualité l'offre de service
ainsi que l'accessibilité postale soit
une réalité dans nos territoires je vous
remercie pour vous répondre de la parole
est au ministre délégué en charge de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications monsieur Barrault
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Patrick chaise merci pour votre
question qui me permet de saluer votre
travail en tant que président de
l'observateur national de la présence
postale vous avez raison il y a quelques
semaines
l'état l'AMF et la Poste ont signé le
sixième contrat de présence possible qui
tire les enseignements du contrat
précédent ainsi que du rapport que vous
avez commis avec vos collègues
pierre-louot et Rémi Cardon avec Bruno
Le Maire Gabriel Attal et Dominique
Faure nous avons veillé à ce que ce
contraste fasse figurer 5 priorités
d'abord le maintien de la la présence
territoriale de la pose dans un contexte
vous l'avez dit de baisse très marqué du
du trafic dans les bureaux de poste en
accompagnement du déploiement du réseau
France service sur lequel veille
attentivement Stanislas guérinis sont
donc 17000 points de contact qui seront
maintenus sur le territoire maintient
d'une dotation de 174 millions d'euros
une plus grande accessibilité horaires
des bureaux de poste notamment le
week-end et lors des événements locaux
le renforcement des actions de médiation
sociale et numériques à destination des
populations vulnérables j'y suis
particulièrement attentif et puis
l'amélioration de la gouvernance des
commissions départementales pour une
meilleure utilisation du fonds de
péréquation il faut rappeler que toutes
ces actions financées sur ce contrat
vont bénéficier prioritairement au
territoire ruraux au territoire de la
politique de la ville aux zones de
montagne et au territoire
ultramarins et puis rappeler pour
répondre à votre question que le
gouvernement s'est engagé à ce que ce
soutien se poursuive par une dotation
qui sera discutée dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances 2024 2025 et
dont vous aurez à débattre vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur sous l'autorité de
la première ministre le gouvernement
extrêmement vigilant à ce que la Poste
puisse remplir dans les meilleures
conditions sa mission de service public
monsieur chaise oui merci monsieur le
Président merci Michel le ministre pour
votre réponse qui me laisse beaucoup
d'espoir vous comprendrez bien que la
sous-compensation et l'augmentation des
dépenses obligatoires aujourd'hui
assèche ce système
sans rien ne modifier de façon favorable
on rend incohérent les discours et les
actes alors pour redevenir cohérent je
vous donne l'occasion de ce ministre
d'améliorer la sous compensation pour
faire en sorte que les Français aient
confiance en vous merci
je voudrais
informer le Sénat que des candidatures
pour siéger au sein de la commission
mixte paritaire chargé d'élaborer un
texte sur les dispositions résidents en
discussions du projet de loi relatif aux
Jeux Olympiques paralympiques de 2024 et
pourtant autres dispositions étaient
publiées ces candidatures seront
ratifiées si la présidence n'a pas reçu
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement merci madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le 5 avril à 15h
je vais lever la séance et notre
prochaine séance aura lieu le mardi 4
avril 2023 à 9h30 pour les questions
orales la séance est levée